-Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show"!
Thank you for watching.
Thank you for being here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, this weekend,
President Biden went after
big social-media platforms
like Facebook
for not doing enough to stop the
spread of COVID misinformation.
Yeah.
Our country has gone from
"The only thing we have
to fear is fear itself"
to "Please don't take
medical advice from a meme."
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, you know there's
a problem with Facebook
when you can find more honest
information on Tinder.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, Biden doesn't want
Facebook to prevent young people
from getting vaccinated.
Everyone under 30
heard and was like,
"That is so cute, but literally
none of us use Facebook.
But that is so..."
[ Laughter ]
"Aww."
Yep, Biden and his
administration are busy.
In fact, they're now reversing
a Trump-era rule
that made showerheads
have more water flow.
[ Laughter ]
In response, Trump spent the day
inciting a riot
in the plumbing section
of a Home Depot.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of Trump,
check out what the authors
of a new book said
about the recent interview
with the former president.
-At one point
in the 2 1/2-hour sitdown
with the book's authors
at Mar-A-Lago,
Mr. Trump suggested
that if George Washington
came back from the dead
and chose Abraham Lincoln
as his vice president,
it would have been very hard,
he says, for them to beat him.
[ Laughter ]
-If George Washington
came back from the dead
and chose Lincoln
as his running mate.
Does Trump think
Abe Lincoln's still alive?
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys, the Olympics
are almost here,
and the athletes
in the Olympic village
are sleeping on beds
made of cardboard.
And some people think
that they're meant
to discourage any intimacy.
[ Laughter ]
That's nice.
You finally reach
your Olympic dreams and have
to sleep on an Amazon box.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, a bed designed
to discourage sex,
or as it's also known,
an air mattress.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
That's right.
'Cause of COVID,
organizers want to make sure
every athlete is as celibate
as a badminton player.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, we're gonna get letters
from the badminton people.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cymbals crash ]
Yeah, everyone's
been talking about these beds,
so a gymnast from Ireland
put them to the test
in a viral video that he posted.
This is great.
Check this out.
-The beds are meant
to be anti-sex.
They're made out of cardboard,
yes, but apparently,
they're meant to break
at any sudden movements.
It's fake.
Fake news!
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, it works fine
as long as you have the body
of a 70-pound Irish gymnast.
[ Laughter ]
So you're completely safe as
long as you have sex like this.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Jumpin'.
[ Laughter ]
-Here's some good advice.
Yesterday,
during his weekly address,
Pope Francis urged people
to learn how to take a break
and turn off their phones.
Then the Pope ended his address
by saying, "That's my sermon.
Be sure to smash that
like button and subscribe."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, the Pope said to look
closely at "The Last Supper"
and notice how everyone left
their phones in a pile
at the end of the table.
[ Laughter ]
Jesus was like, "Peter, Matthew,
give up the phone, please."
[ Laughter ]
"We're not gonna do this again,
hence the title."
[ Laughter ]
-Come on!
[ Applause ]
-"What kind of supper
you think this is?"
Some entertainment news.
I read that Paramount+
has ordered
a "Grease" prequel series.
Yeah.
The movie takes place
before the original "Grease,"
which means the actors
will only be about 48.
[ Laughter ]
[As John Travolta] "Can't
believe I'm in high school.
I got these
high school problems."
I think I'm going
through puberty, right?"
[ Laughter ]
"I can't believe --
Look at this new issue
of 'AARP Magazine,' right?
It's amazing!"
[ Laughter ]
"Ha! You guys get
your Social Security checks?
This party's
gonna be on point."
[ Laughter ]
"I love being in high school.
It's unbelievable."
-"I've fallen,
and I can't get up."
-"Oh, my God! There's
Werther's Originals everywhere.
It's amazing, right?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Hey, get this.
Over the weekend,
there was a lot of debate online
about the lyrics
to Bruce Springsteen's song
"Thunder Road."
Some fans think he says,
"Mary's dress sways."
But the rest say it's,
"Mary's dress waves."
Let's hear it.
♪ The screen door slams ♪
♪ Mary's dress sways ♪
-Yeah, interesting.
Not really sure,
but we actually have someone
on the phone right now
who can clear it up.
Bruce, are you there?
-Yeah.
Hey, Jimmy.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you for being here.
Now, I don't know
if you've heard about this,
but people online
were having trouble
understanding your song.
-Oh, yeah, I heard about that.
[ Indiscernible ]
-Right, right.
Well, I imagine a lot
of your fans
have been reaching out
and asking
if it's "sways" or "waves."
-Right.
[ Indiscernible ]
-...sways or waves...
...wave runner wave wave.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you so much for agreeing
to come on the show
and clear things up
once and for all.
Whenever you're ready,
go for it.
-Two, three...
♪ Screen door slams ♪
♪ Mary's dress waaay ♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you so much
for clearing it up.
Bruce Springsteen, everybody.
-Yeah...
[ Indiscernible ] ...Jimmy.
[ Applause ]
-It's "sways."
Sure.
[ Laughter ]
Some business news.
I saw that grocery stores
are now selling frozen
Chuck E. Cheese pizzas.
[ Audience groans ]
And this is fun.
The pizza is also being used
to make the cardboard beds
in the Olympic village.
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
Isn't that amazing?
-Recycle.
-I read about a man in Florida
who was arrested
after crashing a stolen car
through an airport fence
and boarding
a Coast Guard plane.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, I'm not surprised.
It happened in Florida.
I bet --
[ Laughter ]
I bet we could plug in any three
random words or phrases,
and it would link to an actual
Florida news story.
Let's try it.
It's time for
"Florida News Roulette."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Florida News Roulette, yeah ♪
-Now here's how it works.
The computer will generate
three random words,
and we'll see if there's
a Florida news story
based on those words.
Let's get our first three
right now.
[ Beeping ]
Candles, bear mace --
[ Laughter ]
Candles, bear mace,
and Bath & Body Works.
Bear mace?
-Bear mace.
-What's the difference between
bear mace and regular mace?
-About $3.50.
[ Laughter ]
-Not sure how those
could make a news story,
but, hey, in Florida, who knows?
Let's take a look.
-Oh, South Florida.
The search is on tonight
for a man who police say
used bear mace to steal candles
from Bath & Body Works.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow.
[ Applause ]
All right, let's give it
another spin here.
Here we go.
Let's try.
[ Beeping ]
Alligator,
miniature golf, cocktail lounge.
Alligator, miniature golf,
cocktail lounge.
I couldn't even imagine
what this could be.
Let's see.
-A Florida man is in jail
after police officers
spotted him trying
to throw a live alligator
onto the roof of
a beachside cocktail lounge.
Police say the 32-year-old man
told officers he stole the gator
from its pen at a miniature golf
course and was, quote,
"Teaching it a lesson."
-Yeah, that's right.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's right, man.
Taught him a lesson.
-Showed him.
-Absolutely.
Showed him, man.
[ Laughter ]
-"I'll show you!"
-He was teaching the alligator
a lesson.
-The alligator was rude.
-That's right. Absolutely.
-I'm gonna throw you on top --
-But he was trying to...
-Yeah, he was trying.
Alligator didn't
learn his lesson.
Let's try one more time.
Here we go.
What have we got?
[ Beeping ]
Everglades,
emergency landing, taco.
-Taco.
-All right.
Let's see what happens.
-A couple of guys had to make
an emergency landing
in their plane
in Collier county last week.
They survived and told officials
they were flying across
the Everglades on a taco run.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Big deal.
Needed some tacos.
And, finally, I saw that
there is a Swiss mountain
for sale on eBay for $235,000.
Sounds like a bargain, but the
shipping costs are a fortune.